former President Barack Obama is
criticizing the response to the
coronavirus stepping further into this
2020 campaign and a pair of virtual
graduation speeches over the weekend the
former president urged this year's
graduates to do better this pandemic is
fully finally torn back the curtain on
the idea that so many of the folks in
charge know what they're doing a lot of
them aren't even pretending to be in
charge doing what feels good what's
convenient what's easy that's how little
kids think unfortunately a lot of
so-called grown-ups including some with
fancy titles and important jobs still
think that way which is why things are
so screwed up President Trump who's
criticized mr. Obama repeatedly in
recent days had this response yesterday
O'Keefe is covering campaign 2020 ed why
do you think the former president is
saying this at this particular time
well good morning Gail good to see you
the former president who's largely
stayed silent over the past three years
never mentioned the former or the
current president by name but his
criticism was evident members of the
current administration also weighing in
White House trade adviser Peter Navarro
said Sunday that mr. Obama is now
serving as quote Joe Biden's press
secretary mr. Obama is expected to
actively campaign for Biden through
November and is using his large social
media presence to their advantage
especially with fundraising Biden
himself continues to campaign from his
Delaware home and is planning later this
week to hold a virtual rally with voters
in Wisconsin his team is hiring up to
600 field staffers in about a dozen
battleground states they'll be in place
by June and they'll be doing the
traditional get-out-the-vote work that's
been done in previous campaigns but
mostly from a distance or at least
virtually at the start one spokesman
over the weekend told me the former
president is a quote force and will be
an enormous asset for Democratic
candidates across the country through
election day Anthony
all right dad thank you